la economía en france 24 me acompaña en
el estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida mientras en américa
latina nos queremos vacunar en eeuu
ofrecen de todo para que la gente vaya a
vacunarse si raúl muy buenas noches mire
varios estados
desesperados por persuadir a los
escépticos han lanzado incentivos que
incluyen desde boletos de béisbol y
cerveza gratis hasta becas
universitarias y dinero en efectivo
california por ejemplo destinará 116 5
millones de dólares en efectivo y
tarjetas de regalo y va a sortear dinero
entre el 4 y el 11 de junio escucharás
todos
aquellos que antes de esas fechas se
hayan maquinado espero que estén
prestando atención obtienen una tarjeta
de incentivo de 50 dólares y tienen la
oportunidad de estar en un sorteo donde
sacaremos los nombres de 15 personas que
recibirán premios en efectivo de 50 mil
dólares
raúl y es que hay una gran masa de gente
que no se quiere vacunar dificultando
los planes de las autoridades para
lograr la llamada inmunidad de grupo
pero california no es el único gen ohio
una mujer acaba de ganar un sorteo de un
millón de dólares y en nueva york
activistas regalaron marihuana a quienes
se vacunará hasta la casa blanca lanzó
una colaboración con uber para ofrecer
descuentos en los viajes a los centros
de vacunación yo no sé qué más tiene la
gente entonces daniela las fortunas de
los ricos en américa latina subieron
drásticamente un análisis del programa
de naciones unidas para el desarrollo
llama la atención sobre la profunda
desigualdad que se ha agudizado en
américa latina' tomó cifras de la
revista forbes para concluir que en
marzo de 2020 había 76 multimillonarios
en la región con un patrimonio neto
conjunto de más de 280 mil millones de
dólares en mayo de este año como vemos
la comparación hay un 40% más de ricos
con una fortuna un 70% más alta casi
medio billón de dólares la mayoría de
ellos está en brasil méxico y chile
esos casi 200.000 millones de dólares
raúl para que calculé pues en apenas un
año equivalen al pib de un país como 4 y
en estado y eeuu presentó un ambicioso
proyecto de presupuesto el presidente
joe biden envió al congreso un plan de 6
billones de dólares para el año fiscal
2000 22 mucho más alto que los 44
billones que se gastaron en 2019 antes
de la panda si el legislativo no le
hiciera cambios algo que es casi
improbable
este presupuesto dispararía los niveles
de gasto y de deuda a sus niveles más
altos desde la segunda guerra mundial
incluso teniendo en cuenta que uno de
sus pilares es el aumento de impuestos
corporativos y de renta para los más
adinerados uno de los puntos más
difíciles de negociar es el del plan de
infraestructura un sector al que va a ir
en quiere invertir le 1.7 millones y los
republicanos menos de un billón y el
aumento de los precios de la carne está
modificando los platos de muchos
raúl para nadie es un secreto que la
carne de res está más cara y eso se debe
a varios factores chinas está
reemplazando el cerdo desde un brote de
fiebre porcina en 2018 además del ganado
está escaso y la comida para alimentarlo
está más costosa el alza de precios y
más demanda china están quitando poco a
poco la carne del menú en países de
amplia tradición carnívora como
argentina en donde el gobierno suspendió
temporalmente las exportaciones el
precio ha subido casi un 60% en apenas
un año y el consumo cayó a su nivel más
bajo en un siglo mucha gente que
compraba cortes de los que son más caros
y ahora uno no está que preguntan a ver
si tenemos otra opción por ahí un
poquito más accesible hacemos de un
asado de vez en cuando pero ahora
combinamos con otros otros cortes
que reemplaza en el asado tradicional
punta de paleta colita de cuadril y el
alzado suerte que llame bolivariana
daniel indicadores en wall street del
cerro una semana sin mucha variación
acumulada aunque los índices dow jones y
standard and bolsas lograron su primera
ganancia semanal en canción mes
europa allí hubo varios recorte de esta
semana y algunas cerraron el máximo
histórico el viernes en medio de una
confianza generalizada y en américa
latina la bolsa de sao paulo puso sello
de oro a la semana con nuevo máximo
histórico para finalizar que nuestra de
como cifra el día 1.5 millones de
bicicletas por 2.600 millones de euros
el raúl se vendieron en españa en 2020
marcando récord histórico y creciendo 24
por ciento frente a 2019
daniela gracias por toda la información
ustedes también gracias continua con
nosotros
[Música]